hi i'm ria i'm a tasty producer today
i've been challenged to take a common
food and make it fancy here are today's
rules you must use the food given you
can only add to the food you can buy
whatever ingredients you wish ooh this
is a new role you must wear a halloween
costume this new roll is very exciting
okay let's see what's inside
candy corn candy corn is my least
favorite halloween candy it's kind of
waxy i wasn't sure if it's edible when i
saw this first time i didn't know this
was food even it's three colors it's one
tone flavor
it's not too bad as i remember kind of
has a hint of honey i have some idea for
my costume i have a great idea for candy
corn and i'm excited to make it fancy
here's what i got but first this is my
costume
a lot of people commented and told me
that i look like the girl collette from
the movie ratatouille so i dress up like
her now for the ingredients i got almond
flour butter and eggs from the pantry i
got granulated sugar
powdered sugar turmeric and gel food
color okay let's get started
make it fancy halloween edition
i'm going to
separate three eggs if you're separating
egg and bioxide if you get trace of egg
yolk don't use that because that
contains oil so it's very difficult to
whip the egg whites egg whites has to be
room temperature if it's too cold put it
in a bowl and put the bowl on top of the
hot water and set aside i'm going to use
egg yolk later so i'm also going to set
this aside next step i'm going to
measure one cup of almond flour and one
and three fourths cup powdered sugar and
put in a food processor sometimes stable
almond flour is a little bit too coarse
so i'm going to make it a little bit
finer you don't want to process just by
almond flour because almond flour has a
lot of oil so you want to combine
powdered sugar and almond flour so it
doesn't become too oily next step i'm
going to whip egg whites and sugar
together and i will need a quarter cup
sugar whisk this until it's kind of
flossy add sugar one third at a time
adding sugar gradually egg whites should
look very glossy and he has to have that
hot peak so next i'm going to shift
powder to sugar and almond flour mixture
really what was the first thing we saw
as soon as they came out i think at that
time i also had a disc bob haircut i
also like making ratatouille watching
ratatouille being ratatouille have you
seen our fancy around in the background
yes
it's so fancy it's creepy
now i'm going to mix this until it is
not powdery divide this into two a
teaspoon of turmeric two drops of yellow
gel food color you are going to push
this against the wall eliminating the
bubbles you created it's almost look
like mustard and when you are bringing
up and if it's continuously dropping
that it's the sign of it's done transfer
is in a piping bag very important once
you start mixing you have to move very
quickly because while you're waiting the
batter becomes runny again it's very
critical you have to make sure the right
texture and then you're gonna tap
so the bubbles disappear
i'm going to set this aside and i'm
going to move on the white color same
thing mix push against the wall and mix
if your first timer like i recommend to
count how many times you're mixing you
kind of mix about 35 or 40 times rookie
mistake it's over mixing shout out for
the rookies i hope you guys make it
after watching this episode i think
macaron is one of the most difficult
cookie but you just need practice
we are going to wait for 30 minutes to
one hour until the surface is completely
dried so next step i'm going to use the
egg yolk and i'm going to whisk it until
it become a little bit pale color
set this aside
and candy corn one cup of candy corn
and a quarter cup of water bring it to a
boil and keep it going until the
temperature reaches 230 fahrenheit
so
candy corn is completely melted and it's
bubbling it's perfect for halloween it
looks like witchcraft right now i'm
going to check switch to 2 30 and it
starts smelling good just like vanilla
and sugar add this little by little
basically what i'm doing is pouring hot
candy corn mixture into egg yolks so it
can kill the bacteria in the egg yolk
it's like mild right what else like
melted ice cream well moving on to the
next step i got three sticks of butter
softening room temperatures cut into the
cubes so it's easier to mix this classic
french technique called potabong usually
you mix with egg yolk and boil the sugar
but instead of doing that i melted candy
corn this time
this is a little bit less orange than i
want so i'm going to add food color it
looks like a blood
and you don't want to add too much
because you don't want to make it too
runny so i think this looks good and i'm
going to cover and put in the
refrigerator until i use it next time
these are well rested and the surface is
completely dry now and it's very cute
you have to make sure the surface is
completely dry so you can touch and
nothing comes out from the finger
if it's still wet just dry another like
15 or 30 minutes more but don't let it
dry more than 90 minutes so my oval is
already preheated i'm going to bake this
for 300 fahrenheit for 7 minutes first
and then reduce the heat to 285 and
continue to bake for 10 minutes
all right looks so cute has a little
feet and it's round and perfectly baked
and i already cool this for 10 minutes
after i take out from the oven an
indicator of if the macaron is baked or
not is when it's peeled super cleanly
like this this is done i like using
silpat because it is easier to remove
but if you don't have it you can totally
use baking paper so i'm trying to match
yellow one and white one the same size
if you never made it before you can
print out the same circle and pipe on
top of it i matched all my cookies now
i'm going to get my candy cane
buttercream
so here's my buttercream it's a little
bit cold so butter is a little bit
hardened i'm gonna just mix it so it
will be nice and soft put them in a
piping bag
when i'm piping buttercream i'm kind of
eyeballing but i feel like this is
probably one tablespoon i'm so happy
this is like super orange now i'm gonna
top with the white shell just gently
squish down bring it up and like twist
like this and we are done my candy corn
macaron
[Music]
okay it's time for halloween
trick-or-treaters
[Laughter]
i'm taking a small bite this time yeah
[Music]
they're really good though this looks
like it could be like in a bake shop
like a haul i would definitely go out
and buy these yes to have at my
halloween party so katie yes did i make
candy corn fancy absolutely make it
fancy
i have my friend and partner in crime
for halloween linguini please have a
bite and
tell me what i made fancy
how does it taste very very sweet but
it's good sweet i think i know what it
is and i'm one of the few people that is
a fan of this candy okay it's candy corn
yes
so brandon did i make candy corn fancy
super good so fancy yay
make it fancy happy halloween
i'm a grape you look great
[Laughter]
these are the balloons this took way too
long so you have to blow each one out
i didn't even get to the ones in the
back
oh you're crying
it's almost scary
the idea of a human grape is quite
terrifying
welcome back to make it fancy this looks
fantastic
[Music]
yes
they're just so delightful it's very
sharing a great piece of eating macaroni
this is halloween in a nutshell is it
grape this is great you're grape did i
make this candy corn fancy you
absolutely made this fancy tree
thank you so much for watching i hope
you make candy corn macaroon at home if
you do please tag me on instagram and
don't forget to dance
make it fancy and happy halloween
[Music]
you